Sam Orman announced in the last couple
of hours that CHBT will start trying to
assess whether you are a child and in
some circumstances can flag
conversations for review by parents and
the authorities. For those of us who
aren't children, Chacht will also
sometimes begin flirting. This video
then will give you the 5-minute TLDDR on
this announcement which is not unique to
ChateBT by the way, as well as some
other things Samman said this week that
99% of people may have missed, but a
good chunk of those should hear. First,
the classic corporation speak, which is
that OpenAI are building toward a
long-term system to understand whether
someone is over or under 18. Unless I
missed it, I can't find anywhere where
they announced when this would occur or
whether it starts as of today. One thing
to immediately flag is that as of July,
YouTube already does this based on the
type of videos that you watch. Okay, but
what will Chat GBT do if it assesses
that you're a teen? Well, first of all,
it won't flirt with you ever. And second
of all, in extreme circumstances,
depending on the discussion, it may
contact law enforcement. You may of
course have seen some recent very sad
headlines about why they may have felt
they needed to take this step. Like many
of you, I think the goal is admirable.
The question is they better be really
confident they're flagging the right
conversations. Then comes a really key
sentence. If we are not confident about
someone's age or have incomplete
information, we'll take the safer route
and default to the under 18 experience
and give adults ways to prove their age
to unlock adult capabilities. In the
next 2 weeks, we do know that there will
be parental controls enabling parents
to, for example, of teens set blackout
hours when a teen cannot use chatbt.
Then as before, if the system detects
their teen is in a moment of acute
distress, it will flag to the parent
first and foremost and then only
afterwards to law enforcement. Again, I
totally understand the motivation. I
guess one thing I'd flag to OpenAI is
what happens if like Twitter a foreign
country with different standards asks
them and says according to our law you
have to notify us when X occurs, when a
user says Y about the government or does
zed. Some tech companies cave into that,
others don't. So, only time will tell.
The next two announcements, which came
just an hour ago as of filming, might
have been missed. OpenAI say that they
want to give the same level of
protection to your conversations with AI
as you might have with your
conversations to a doctor or to a
lawyer. They say that people are
increasingly turning to AI for sensitive
questions and about their private
concerns. Interestingly, we learned
today exactly what percentage of people
are turning to chatbt for for different
reasons. I spent about half an hour
analyzing this image earlier and it's
pretty fascinating to see how people use
chatbt. According to this, for the web
version at least, only 4.2% are using it
for coding. That compares to 10% to be
tutoed or taught something and even 5.7%
for fitness, beauty, self-care, or
health advice. I was also kind of
shocked how creating an image was a less
used capability than translation. You
may also notice that4% of people just
spend their time asking about the model.
How are you? Are you conscious? That
kind of thing. Back to the announcement
though. So what could be the concerns
about this greater level of privilege
and privacy it seems for adults. My
concerns are for startups because OpenAI
say we are advocating for this
protection with policy makers. That is
of course therefore the Trump
administration. My concern is that if
OpenAI gets a law passed that any chat
with an AI system has to be protected by
numerous layers of privilege and privacy
and protection. While that sounds good
initially, like needing to pass the bar
to become a lawyer, it raises the bar
literally for all startups and
open-source initiatives. Or at least it
could force them to go through all sorts
of hurdles. That's my concern. Yes, I
know OpenAI will claim that this is just
about stopping the New York Times,
forcing them to retain user data
indefinitely. I guess I'm just a tad
skeptical about the possibility for
regulatory capture. Another theory, by
the way, is it could have been in
response to the FDC launching an inquiry
in America to quote understand what
steps, if any, companies have taken to
evaluate the safety of their chatbots
when acting as companions. Last
announcement from this afternoon before
I get to the quote from Samman that many
people will have missed. I think
practically everyone actually. This is
regarding the question of when chatbt
will flirt with you. And the answer is
simple. If you ask for it, they should
get it. I personally have never asked
HBT to flirt, but presumably some of you
have and have seen the model refuse.
Well, apparently it won't do so anymore.
If the system then believes you're an
adult or you have been forced to provide
ID showing you're an adult, it will now
also help you write a fictional story
that involves presumably, let's say,
extreme flirtation and a self-caused
tragedy. I guess you could summarize all
of these announcements is that they're
great if we could perfectly trust OpenAI
to implement them correctly. If those
were the announcements, what was the
quote that almost everyone miss? Well,
first for some context, here's what Sam
Alman was telling lawmakers in the US in
private in 2024.
>> Want to talk a little bit about the
workforce, but Mr. Alman, uh, when we
met last year in my office and had a a
great conversation, uh, you said that
upwards of 70% of jobs could be
eliminated, uh, by AI. Uh, and you
acknowledge the possible social
disruption of this. Uh, if that's
happening, we have to prepare for it.
We're not going to stand in the way of
the incredible opportunities here.
>> Now, Samman did not backtrack from that
quote when speaking to the Senate, but
here's an interview he did just a few
days ago with Tucker Carlson. You'll see
for yourself. But he implies that it
could be towards the end of this century
that the job ramifications fully play
out.
>> There's going to be massive displacement
and maybe those people will find
something new and interesting and
lucrative to do. But what how big is
that displacement do you think?
>> Someone told me recently that the
historical average is about 50% of jobs
significantly change. Maybe they don't
totally go away, but significantly
change every 75 years on average. That's
the kind of that's the halfife of the
stuff. My controversial take would be
that this is going to be like a
punctuated equilibri moment where a lot
of that will happen in a short period of
time, but if we zoom out, it's not going
to be dramatically different than the
historical rate. Like we'll do we'll
have a lot in this short period of time
and then it'll somehow be less total job
turnover than we think. Some may say
that's a case of giving different
opinions in public versus in private.
Others might say, well, he's just
changed his mind. I've spent the last
week or so preparing a video for my
Patreon on this fascinating paper, Why
Language Models Hallucinate. And I'm
trying to get an interview with the
author. Essentially, it argued that we
already have a literature on
mclassification in machine learning
models. Years before language models, we
figured out why it's intractable how
classifiers can sometimes get wrong. Is
this a cat or is it a dog? What the
paper does essentially is map the
problem of classification to that of
generation, i.e. language models.
Because we force models to output one
response rather than a probability
distribution of responses, they're
essentially forced to sometimes BS.
Multiple choice benchmarks, like my own
simple bench, are part of the problem
because it always rewards guessing over
saying, "I don't know." Solving that
will be a sociotechnical problem. But
anyway, that was the massive summary.
That's not the point of this video. But
I wonder if Samman read this and is
gradually adjusting his opinion. The
paper was so thoughtprovoking for me and
it will be linked in the description.
Created this grid on what the blockers
are to the singularity and how they can
be overcome. Kind of got carried away
and created visualizations for each of
the categories. But anyway, that's for
another day. But I do want to be fair to
Sam Orman because he's often vilified
for changing his mind. But he's not
actually the only one. There's one
figure who's almost universally praised
and I respect him massively. He comes
from my neck of the woods, Deis Alvis.
And people say I sound like him. Of
course, he's the Nobel Prizewinning
leader of Google Deep Mine, but let's
just say he's capable of his own about
turns. It's not just Sam Orman. Back in
December of 2023, I think I was one of
the only people to really focus on a
particular quote from Deisarvis and you
listened to the hype he attached to
Gemini. I think this was Gemini 2 or 1.5
Pro, beating human experts. we started
seeing that Gemini was better than any
other model out there on these very very
important benchmarks. For example, each
of the 50 different subject areas that
we tested on um it's as good as the best
expert humans in those areas. Did you
catch that? In 50 different domains,
different subjects better than human
experts. Now, I debunked that quote both
at the time and more recently, so I'm
not going to debunk it again. But here
Demis is just the other day dunking on
competitors and how their leaders say
that the models are as smart as experts.
That's not something he would ever do
for sure.
>> You often hear some of our competitors
talk about uh you know these modern
systems that we have today are PhD
intelligences. I think that's a
nonsense. They're not they're not PhD
intelligences. They have some
capabilities that are PhD level but
they're not in general capable and
that's what exactly what general
intelligence should be of of performing
across the board at the PhD level. In
fact, as we all know interacting with
today's chat bots, if you pose the
question in a certain way, they can make
simple mistakes with even like high
school maths um and and simple counting.
Do you agree that that was a bit of an
about face having earlier said that
Gemini Ultra was as good as the best
human experts in 50 different subjects?
For me, this is a deceptively
interesting time in AI for all of the
reasons given in this video and far
more. Almost every week, there is a
significant improvement in how language
models can help us code and do software
engineering. And yes, I do think that's
relevant even if you don't code. One of
my goals for perhaps the end of this
year or maybe next is to show how you
can build a production level app just
with the help of AI. That's even without
a coding background by the way. Now, I
guess that would be creating your own
job, but the more traditional path would
be using a job board like this one from
the sponsors of today's video, 80,000
hours. You can use my own link found in
the description to take you to this job
board which is updated I was going to
say almost every day but I think it's
multiple times per day. These are real
jobs from across the world. Some of them
remote and some of them in person. The
focus is of course on having a positive
impact and the jobs as you can see are
sourced not just from AI labs or
universities but also think tanks and
other organizations. Again if you want
to check them out do use the link in the
description. So, which of those for you
was the most interesting announcement?
For me, they're all interesting from the
deeply technical like the hallucinations
paper to the deeply social and emotional
like the child protections. Thank you
anyway for watching this brief recap.